Bob and you know when to like fill in
the gaps and whatnot and I really
appreciate that as well thank you I'd
like to point out an error a recent
error of George though yeah there was
there about three weeks ago he uploaded
Bobby no this no after the compliments
we talked yeah he do Bobby doesn't know
this but on an episode with was it Joe
you whipped your penis out not too dumb
found it but just like to pull it out in
your hand towards me like I check out
you did and George did not blur it and
the episode had been uploaded let me
pull it down because so many people saw
your little wiener not little it was
like not I'm just saying it wasn't a
hard choice of words please it was a
wait wait you showed my dick on the
internet you showed your dick first you
know there's cameras here I it is my
fault
ultimately but it took a long time for
me to slip up of all the blurs I have
done sir
a lot of layers right now okay if that
ever happens again you're out with me oh
my god
please don't leave if that happens I'm
telling you right now because that could
get point out to me give me potential to
get me in a lot of try no but you
weren't like showing your dick to
anybody but me yes it matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter yeah it's not
because I'm afraid I'm gonna get fired
from my show or the backlash is that
it's one of the sacred it's a sacred
entity it's like showing somebody like
you know the that that was the scrolls
that they found was it like an elder
scroll the scroll is one of the Ten
Commandment no those scrolls that they
found in the Red Sea that Dead Sea
Scrolls is what I meant to say your
scrotum is a Dead Sea scroll it looks
like algae
one seaweed it's a magic it's a magic
it's a magical item is basically what
I'm saying and it's got history and it's
ancient its wrinkly because it's wise
and very wise it's very wise and it's
omnipotent mm-hmm and there's a word for
you just don't just blow my dick out yes
sir
okay yes sir
[Music]
[Music]